this is food chain and in honor of it we
ate jewelry but it's ok because she'll
become us as the cartoon suggests and
she'll be animated by a completely
different person and not be in Cannon
and so and so forth ah how can I explain
this one this is it is written and
directed by different animated do we get
the name I don't remember his name
no I said I don't know his name but for
me you know what personally we were very
harsh on glitch is a glitch and we knew
nothing about it I think we should do
the exact same thing with this
well I'd not know anything about the
direct exact okay no fair enough
that's a very certain didn't yell at us
saying you know you know why didn't for
one one to do your research which by the
way I think it's pointless to do
research on this episode for you because
then it gives everything away come on so
I think you know for this we should stop
touching me oh thank you thank you
you're welcome
it's gonna be very blue V look we got on
a blue sky right now doing that so no I
don't think we should do find out
anything about him so we're not safe I
know it is so we can judge it just on
what it is and we know it's not an April
Fool's episode if it was I mean I think
we could I think we can still talk about
just as it as it is um it's an episode
pretty much just teaching about the food
chain I suppose it's been and Jake there
at this I guess caterpillar museum or
something like that I don't know a good
Natural History no no no no I was a
caterpillar Museum it was all about
Canada let's be caterpillars now you're
gonna eat caterpillar is that okay Bri
we took brie to numerous things where
they have like the bubble station and
the that's Willie Wonka's factory
Children's Museum that's where there's a
whole bunch of different
they're active things okay so maybe it
was there in the caterpillar part of
that weed there's a tutorial one yeah
just say it caterpillar so so they
go and Magic Man is there and he
transforms them he transforms Finn and
Jake into birds and then into bigger
birds and then into bacteria and then
into plants plants and then into kids
pillow okay we have birds and then
bigger birds I'm like okay what's their
smaller bacteria or bigger because I
will slowly explained it all well I was
too busy ignoring it because it was so
strange
that's why I do a strange things it's
like I don't see you on except um so
yeah and then the circle of life
continues and they sing a little song
about at the end that's pretty much it
um way better than the damn Lion King
well I mean what do you expect when you
have Matthew Broderick as tomorrow yeah
my mistake so the first thing that Joe's
to my attention honestly is I actually
really did like the animation this one
whoever this person is and it's clearly
a different style but it's um I like
sort of the shading of that like the
motion of it it's it almost parts that
almost felt Disney ish like in just how
cartoon like when a bird eats the worm
it's very you know the mouth gets really
big as well and then the belly gets big
and then it sort of goes small again the
head has to sort of it I was very
flowing um and this means the only
animation this rose
I know I said it's very disney-esque it
just has that
okay I might put this way continue no it
wasn't like because the venture time
animation is usually like very it's very
good untie
and comedy and stuff with Disney
animation even though I love animation
usually isn't sometimes they can get a
good one but if their comic animation is
usually a little off with some
exceptions like every spook crew was
kind of funny the land had some fine
stuff
um but yeah so I dug that the episode
seems kind of pointless and it seems
very much sort of like a weird you know
it felt very dreamlike I almost where I
had a dream like this honestly just for
a second now you're a bird no you're a
flower now you're bacteria now you just
become things and then it's like there's
a wee little socket sit out of my dreams
are like that and it seemed kind of
David Lynch ish like David Lynch was
more upbeat baby um so but I like all
that stuff so I wasn't you know like III
liked him more than a glitch is a glitch
cuz it was nice to look at and it was
just so bizarre and so surreal um which
I guess glitch is a glitch was too but
it didn't feel this one just felt so I
mean it was awkward again I guess like
how glitches the glitches but I felt
more comfortable in its awkwardness it
didn't feel like it was trying to make
it didn't feel like it was trying to
make you laugh constantly glitch is a
glitch felt like it was like you know
and sometimes I'll admit I got a laugh
out of it but for the most part it's
just sort of like I think that I was
supposed to snicker at that but it
didn't work where this one was more like
just the feeling and the mood is
supposed to be kind of funny and strange
so that's what I took out of it I I
guess I like to find I would have liked
it if it did tie in somehow um and I
don't know the whole just totally not
connecting to anything in this instance
and with glitch is a glitch at least
questions glitch what's at April Fool so
I kind of get that but when it seems
like they're just gonna keep doing this
where they bring in guest animators just
to do something has nothing to do with
anything if they won't do that that's
their thing I just feel it's like you
can connect it somehow or if it's not
going to come
to make it so so creative in how it
doesn't connect like at least glitch is
a glitch was April Fool's episode you
know which doesn't make me like if I at
least respected a touch more so I'm kind
of all over the map with this I like
because it was animated so nicely and it
was just creative enough and they have
such a weird mood that I guess I enjoyed
it enough it's not like one of my
personal favorites but you know it's I I
guess I dug it okay that's my tape yes
the one reason why it worked for me
unlike glitch is a glitch is magic men
magic man like if you notice like up
until Magic Man appeared like and change
them into birds it was kind of a normal
episode but the style was a little
different certainly like a whole thing
yeah okay the weird crap that these
these characters go through anyways a
caterpillar Museum are you having that
surprised no it sounds right I mean it's
something a man shows up and just poof
and then it goes all bizarre and crazy
and weird and crap and then at the end
he goes to change and it goes back to
normal and it's like okay I kind of can
accept that
oh and a glitch is a glitch why didn't
they do the big song sequence at the end
ah no that was entirely going back well
yeah but that's in his mind
did you see the real start going yeah
and his eyes opened up and then the
lights came out and then he turns into
is and I was in his mind to do yeah yeah
okay so for me GUCH is a glitch was just
kind of like there you knew it wasn't
canon they made no qualms that it wasn't
Canon it was just kind of there which
kind of yeah with this one at least they
try the pull unquote to make it canon
cuz with magic man any weird crap can
happen and it can still work because
it's magic man doing crazy crap so for
me it actually worked better than
glitches of glitch because of that if
you took out magic man and it was just
this I would have probably disliked it
as much it's pretty
it's nice to look at and I love the
music but I did tend to drag though yeah
there was a point where I'll serve like
one or two of the endings because it has
a couple labs really I was sort of like
even though it's like it's fine I was
counting really we're still kind of go
with an adventure time they're only
eleven minutes and when you're sort of
checking your phone at eleven minutes to
say it's fine not a good sign
yeah I mean I liked it it was
interesting was creative kids can
actually learn something from this yeah
but yeah it did tend to go a bit longer
than it should have heard at least it
felt it did and like I said if it wasn't
for Magic Man I think this episode would
have failed for me
he's like that piece that makes it okay
bizarre crap happens all the time
whenever he's around I can accept this
like if Magic Man wasn't glitch is a
glitch I'd be okay with it like it was
all because of him like changing it into
that I would have been perfectly fine
with it because Magic Man you just like
screwed what things I liked it for me it
I think the reason I liked it first of
all the animation is so engaging yeah I
really I remember like halfway through
the episode I was like it doesn't even
matter that there's no point to this
episode at all because it's so cute
there's just so much visually
stimulating anything in the lighting yes
may I say you had wonderful motion too
but they say like particularly the song
at the end I mean it's like you really
those lights were really I mean you just
almost felt the lens flare off of it
yeah for me it reminded me a lot and I
know it's so stupid and you'll get it
but it reminded me a lot of Japanese
films like it reminded me of executive
koala a little bit you know like when
they're changing into the birds and the
this and and especially when Finn is
like the giant um the giant bird the
bigger bird or whatever and he's
drooling and he's trying but you get my
mouth and I just I don't know why but I
was like oh my
and then that end part that weird dance
song and dance type part it reminded me
of just at Sioux circle yeah where you
know like the bowling and the musical
scene and the bowling alley it's just it
felt very Japanese to me in that it
reminded me of a lot of Japanese movies
that I've seen that necessarily comedies
or even animate but like I think this
guy is Asian and I know a lot of those
seeing it explained you're saying I
could rob at some point show me like the
sort of Japanese characters like for
little little kids you know sort of like
toddlers and the style is very similar
to like when they were the bacteria and
when they were the caterpillar it was
very simple it it almost looks like the
lines are drawn by crabs but like you
know yeah yeah yeah like it actually
kind of works and but they kind of keep
going back and forth so I like that it's
like some parts it looks like the lines
are kranj other times they're very well
shaded and they blend in very nicely so
it's sort of a nice variety in there too
yeah which I like um I think that's what
it has going for it for me particularly
is that I can almost forgive the lack of
story and honestly it's probably one of
the most pointless episodes there are
yeah but you know obviously you probably
even more than glitches a glance really
yeah actually I have to say glitch is a
glitch for me visually was was uh I mean
horrendous it was how I just for
whatever reason it assaulted my sense of
things who didn't take it but really if
you think about the story it's so that's
like a decent story this one has like
nothing and yet I'm gushing but it's
just again it it's distracted me from
the fact that it has no story by giving
me so much visual input to enjoy and not
just to see but to actually enjoy so
yeah I think I would I love the idea of
bringing in different animators to do
sort of different episodes and even if
they sort of want to step out of the
bowl of the Adventure Time mold it's
like that's my I do kind of wish there
was the
more creative way to either tie it into
a story or just make it you know the
idea of them bringing animators just
have it be so far removed like if it
always was an April Fool's thing I would
actually sort of understand that a bit
more I don't know if you can only do
April Fool's because I did they don't
always land on that day yeah
you know but I don't know I'm very up in
the air about it because it does seem
like when you have just like this guy
really was a really cool animator and
did some really creative stuff here is
it man what would you love to see that
apply to something like you know just a
dream sequence where Finn finds out
something or it doesn't have to even be
part of a big story but is something
else that are you talking more like
James Baxter how he just came in and
just animated the horse and did the
voice if it's a whole episode done by a
different animator honestly or RV
totally wants to submerge yourself into
style I wish there's a little bit more
connection as to making the reasoning a
little bit more unique as to as to why
or how it connects to anything like so
even if they were all just April Fool's
episodes um but at the same time I guess
I kind of respect the randomness of it
too that they'll just do it whenever I
mean it's just so strange so like I said
I'm really I'm really half-and-half on
it but I definitely like this one a lot
more I thought it was very like I'm a
very creative just a very at times kind
of boring but still very mellow surreal
mood that my dog and I I thought was it
was enjoyable I already said my thing I
said my thing I said words you know I
like this better than glitches a glitch
but they also gave a reason why this
could potentially be happening I like
even if you took the reasoning out it's
I don't know if that still works me is I
think it works technically well enough
and I and basically created a bunch of
little people for Finn to play with you
could turn them into birds and
caterpillars I know I know it's like
technically it works but you know
everything
yeah yeah I mean okay if glitch is like
if they had like I said Magic Man in the
beginning of a glitch is a glitch or the
moment they put in that floppy that Ice
King sent them and boom it started to
turn computer-generated yeah then I
would have felt like it was a natural
progression for Magic Man
what was the opening what was up with
the opening magic man's already in her
broom he's behind the couch wait wait
that's how that's why the opening is all
weird and everything is he's in the room
of everybody watching us oh just us yeah
also all the are people I didn't see
that opening we're like oh okay good to
know
yeah do you feed him why he doesn't need
food he can make his own food sure plus
he also feeds on your confusion sure
he's food
must be very for poor guy I'd say he's a
piece really obese hey can we have this
nap please this is being foolish and oh
no let's just stare at the camera I like
a good luck minute what do you say cuz
the clock says you know seven
eight-by-ten will go til you know full
great